what they are doing is they are trying
to ratchet up the fear all the democrats
have they've wrecked the economy supply
chain gas prices inflation ridiculous
war
in ukraine all of this stuff they've
done the border all the stuff that we
talked about all the time right they've
done so much bad that they need the only
thing they've got is fear and anger and
we're going to live in
this time where they're going to be
coming for women and it's going to be
like the handmaid's tale and blah blah
blah blah
well here's nancy pelosi and
you know she's using her scare tactics
although i will give nancy a little
credit whatever work she had done over
the last couple days they seem to have
done the fillers right she's looking a
little better than usual right now
instead of people going off on what
the
what the republicans would like us to
talk about the leak no we're talking
about
your life
the life of women in our country and how
we have uh again a calibration of all of
this in roe v wade and how we must have
it be enshrined as the law of the land
this is a severe danger
to women it's a severe danger to the
constitution of the united states and
it's a sphere of danger to other rights
of privacy that are in the constitution
okay none of that is true it is not a
danger to women guys i'm not a
mathematician but i think about half
people are women that means half of the
babies are women so you're kind of
protecting some of the women again this
doesn't even matter what you think about
abortion but the fear they're coming for
women they're coming for privacy they're
coming for the constitution this is the
constitution working the constitution
working is constitutional supreme court
justices looking at the decisions and
making the appropriate decision you may
not like it and again i say this knowing
that most of my audience right now most
of my audience how many people that are
that are on youtube or twitter or
cnn or elsewhere would say something
that is directly contrary to their
audience but most of my audience is
pro-life i know that for sure
i am begrudgingly pro-choice at least
for a few weeks i would say 12 weeks
you've got three months and i just
believe that there is a fundamental
difference between the cells splitting
and the form and the and the brain
activity and the heartbeat and all of
those things it's not to deny its life
you guys know my spiel on this thing
but we could have an honest discussion
about that we could have an honest
discussion about 15 weeks that florida's
doing and florida passed the 15-week
thing and nobody cared nobody cared
because it shows you that pro-life
people as as personal
and as closely as they hold their own
religious beliefs about the nature of
life like the most existential stuff
they're they're showing but we're
willing to live in a in a society that
has some room for margin right that has
some ability to some people are going to
do some things we don't like what we
don't want is eight month abortion so
florida did 15 they passed this a few
weeks ago nobody cared i can't say
nobody cared but but it was allowed to
pass without major fanfare because most
people saw that as a decent compromise
but florida will now be painted and of
course ron desantis will now be painted
as these crazy right-wing extremists
because these people lie about
everything and here is another crazy
person this is one of the members of the
squad don't worry it's not aoc or elon
omar
this is ayanna presley she is completely
these people
are just
bananas
we have got to codify roe v way we
should
abolish the filibuster
it is clear that this supreme court
continues to obstruct the will of the
people because majority of americans
um support roe v wade do not want it
overturned
and the far-right extremism of this
supreme court has obstructed the will of
the people when it comes to voting
rights when it comes to housing rights
and now when it comes to reproductive
freedom justice and bodily autonomy so
if you're not outraged you are not
paying attention you know the fact that
50
of those who call this country home
uh could have our rights taken away from
us our bodily autonomy and uh
be forced
to birth
with all of the other many uh layered uh
legislative systematic oppression and
denials and everything and then we have
not yet to uh enact uh parental leave
paid leave we do not have universal
child care we have a black women
experiencing the highest rates of
maternal morbidity and now forced birth
and we know that it is our most
vulnerable our most marginalized um the
disabled low-income uh women of color
african-american indigenous the our
lgbtqi
a siblings who will be the most
vulnerable to this we have to legislate
organize mobilize as if lives depend on
it because they do
what you just saw there was a mishmash
of all of the buzzwords all of the
meaningless phrases all of the conflated
and confused ideas of what a progressive
is
of course this is a far right this is a
far right court because anything that
happens that you wouldn't like is far
right and what she means by that is
racist and then of course she tells us
how we're all systemically racist and
that we're forcing black women to have
kids that's the worst thing you can do
to a woman force a woman to have a kid
who's pregnant that would oh my god
they're gonna have a kid they got
pregnant and they're gonna have a kid
that is dead is just the workforce
to birth it's the far-right extremism of
the
it's all meaningless drivel and then
when she's talking about it and child
pay and all of these things it's like
those are the big government programs
you want that has nothing to do with how
we're governed it has nothing to do with
the laws of the united states and one
more time guys by the way this idea of
packing the court that is an assault on
the constitution we have three branches
of government i know that your wizard
aoc does not know that but we have three
separate branches they have checks and
balances to make sure none gets too
powerful so if you use your power to
overpower another branch you are in
violation of your oath of office start
impeaching these people i'm not kidding
they're telling you we hate america we
hate the founding documents we want to
assault the constitution
that's the thing that they swore on most
of them
you